NCAA level and also in the minor leagues as
melli will send one towards the front try
to poke it home buad it ends up into the corner
that's where it's played and sent Along by Zack
Benson and it'll be flipped along opportunity
in over the line it goes Carone to the net he
can't get a pass Lucan in oh great speed there
by Kone Fearless taking that puck to the cage
T's leader and goals look at this pass by Zucker
just a backhand saucer with speed rumbling down
that left side throws that right leg out and
cuts to the net protects that Puck and almost
tucks it in think he was trying to go five
hole you alamak and now kerin will play it
along it's like the first round Club out there
right now for Buffalo to the front SMS with a
shot and stopped by Lucen oh you would have
loved to see Nick smallz hit the score sheet
no points in his last five games and just one
shot on net in his last three for Nick schz I
know he was questionable last night in the game
so obviously something's bugging him a little
bit take it away and skinning it along Payton
Krebs and he'll get it back from darene KBS
with it h over the line prbs with a shot a stop
there caraa aronal carry it to Center brought
it in Carone holding carcone shooting over the
top Austin KRA tries to take him off the point
Patera real good player JJ Patera as this one
sent to the front and fromel able to cover to
get a face off drops it stetcher holding on to
it is schaltz where Andre turny is so good that's
what makes him such a good bench coach Keller's
got it again rolls in and covered by luukinen
as dinino playing in behind the net coyot still
without Travis boy Barrett hton and vladislav
Kia Chona call on IR pulio take it away to the
front Liam o'b up high and a stop by Lucan Liam
with a great look brought in Lawson Krauss they
get it set up for zooker out to the line melli
suer shoot stop P St tried to get the rebound he
got knocked over looking for a penalty a little
little shaky there KBS plays it in behind that
Travis derit rolls right to Vela he'll get a
face off and denied and PCO will get back JJ Peta
for Middle stat middle stat right down Broadway
and covered by Mela all sorts of room and Carell
with his best stop of the night hockey game they
kick it outside in Middle stat look at all the
time and space that he has it was that Center
Lane Drive that took Vela right or excuse me
valami right out of the play and middlestead
just kind of threw it right at that right
pad great second effort there by Vela you
watch that left right pad right there double
kick Carell can get his uh game on track and
get support more than anything as he bats that
one away and he will yeah he will yeah I agree
Johnson shot that's deflicted white that'll be
one heck of a one-two combo for the coyotes into
the corner Moser look to get it out now Conor
Clifton CLI him behind the net Rasmus D with
a shot and a stop Benson in front had the game
winning goal last night in Vegas that game was
tight until the third period of play and then
they just put the clamps on him as bu step sent
one wide added away rebound in front oh what
a look thought melli might have one off the
rebound and now kessle ring he thought he had
one too save crb the other way for Buffalo B it
away look out rebound over the top of poo good
look now Clayton Keller cutting to the middle
he lost the pocket ATI Samuelson up for Middle
stat PKA trying to get around balamaki PKA with
a shot and a stop Thea and petka comes back 25
to go in the period JJ petera shoots ped Away by
Thea just his Edge work his ability to to walk
the line and get shot through as you just saw
little drop Thompson GL save as it out of the Zone
Jason zooker giveway here YY Haru the other way
and a shot off the [Applause] bar Kio skated out
to Center Zack Sanford back to coie to Sanford
backhander to the front rebound O'Brian was there
but he can't get it pass Luc it five days six
days out of the Zone it goes middle stat will pick
it up here he comes middle stat the trailer and a
stop by mamela oh what a stop as he absolutely
robs Ryan Johnson third wave for the Buffalo
Sabers Dumba played that perfectly and what a pass
right there on the muddy and Johnson tries to go
up over that blocker just didn't get it up quite
enough on carala Mala that is a poked away derit
look out here Benson for Yoki Haru and a shot
towards the front and mamela able to pounce on
it yeah that was tuck right in front my goodness
that's catlike partner unbelievable sequence
carova razor sharp right [Music] now Ryan Johnson
try to get it back for aoso that one goes all the
way back down the length call the Coy's catch up
break there nothing in the tank for kessle ring
and dur taken away to the front they scor it's
Keller and who fished it out Alex kerwood one
nothing coyotes [Applause] [Music] all that
pressure that was an aired pass by Johnson
and the turnover by the tender horrible turnover
after his team just dominating the coyotes gives
it up to kerfoot and Clayton Keller that is a
gift and he will absolutely take it his second
point in the last six games for Clayton Keller
and that's got to feel good for him [Applause]
Little Feather pass steter spinner amama stetcher
to the front P save oh Lucin that time Keller
again and another save by Lucan and a minute
nine remaining in the power play yeah that Top
Line will come out now oh turnover tuck steals it
away pad sa AA comes in front again Thompson he's
Deni and now Jo kerfoot all over it again
drops it schaltz has it schaltz shoots off
the end boards to the front kerfoot can't
buy it oh Keller was coming late as well
that's little battle Factor but look at
kin all over this one strips the putt
from the Buffalo Savers there's the Chance
by schz that comes right out in front watch
this Puck after the shot of schz comes
right through the legs of the Sabers
goenda and Clayton Keller as well
with another whack at it Robinson
shot partially deflected Away by steter how's
look to get it out Liam O'Brien he's got some
room Liam O'Brien is in O'Brien Scores Bar
down for Liam it's two [Applause] [Music]
nothing that's a guy that does all the
dirty work great stick there by [__]
look at the wheels on Liam O'Brien and
he knows he's running out of real estate
he keeps this on the back hand and he
goes bar down baby that's as good as it
gets back out High buat trying to go
the distance it's going to roll all
the way down won't matter coyotes have
won both games this weekend Homestead